bon la nouvelle jetée pas comment et là
je vais monter sur scène pour
l'humoriste
je sais à 25 ans il veut tout près vrai
qu'à beaucoup pris un pari bon état des
gilets quelques chaudes et puisse à la
fois j'étais au feu rouge avait un mec
qui ce curé mais croise trop ils sont
tous elle doit prendre demain c'est à
dire vers le français
[Musique]
vous faites
1995 bruxelles à droite c'est moi lille
a un ça va
c'est le début des ennuis lui c'est mon
père omar c'est les filles font la danse
ou gymnases et 2 c les balances du
quartier que du noir le bord hippolyte
et les arabes aussi
je voulais une danseuse mais mon père
avec d'autres projets pour moi je fais
déchirer vos passeports
je vais vous envoyer aux blettes j'ai ma
mère et vous allez faire d'humour sur
les captures mais quinze ans après
j'étais toujours à fond j'avais qu'une
idée en tête tenter ma chance à part
laisse moi t'expliquer tu m'as entier
verra taïwan expliquent étoffé souvent
toi c'est moi qui dicte les règles
moment avec mon père c'était toujours
aussi compliqué bon la nouvelle tulle je
te paie commande est là et grâce à
fabrice je me lançais dans le stand-up
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le choix aux
besoins de ce tremplin je veux me
prouver que je suis capable
non papa tombé à on parle de toi qu'est
ce que tu veux toi je vais monter sur
scène bourg tribord histoire c'est la
paille rien qu'en jour toutes les
variables pour pouvoir y monter résidait
quelque chose de puissant dernière fois
j'étais au feu rouge avait un mec qui se
curer le nez il croise trop ils sont
tous elle bien pour moi pour debarnot
c'est à dire là le français
m
si vous laissez le parcours initiatique
d'une jeune femme qui croise connais
j'ai tout niké d'accord y'a personne
comme un dingue et croit qu'il est
rageant
nous en quoi est-ce que vous êtes pas
à